tonight it's dallas kykel on the mound
average fastball velocity dan
87.5 miles an hour no but you go back to
his days with the houston astros and he
can get ground balls at will you'll know
early if he's on greg he's not an
overpowering guy you touched on it 86 to
89 miles an hour good hard cutter and
then he'll use that changeup you'll know
early if he's on the infielders should
be in play a ground ball machine oh
that's what you want that's a base hit
though you think
makata
makes the play take that harold reynolds
it's a nice play and you know what made
that really nice
that ball's rolling so often you want to
bare hand that ball right but if the
ball's rolling that fast use a glove he
used the glove in the transfer remember
this guy came up as a second baseman so
this is a transfer as if he is turning
two there's not a lot of third basemen
that have that quick of a transfer oh
nelson cruz this looks good off the bat
and the boom stick strikes first i was
feeling it too i almost said something
that upsets me
he's throwing too many balls up high he
did it to donaldson and he fortunately
got donaldson with two strikes on the
sinker but remember the gift we said he
got a gift yep everything's up so kaiko
can't be up this ball is above the waist
no hitter
in dallas kykel's career has hit more
home runs off of him than nelson cruz
that is now his sixth career homer
hitting over 400 against dallas caico
that's ownership he had a problem giving
up the home run ball 2019 to 2020 over
40 home runs he's calm that down he's
strong to his glove side you'll see him
cut the ball in on right-handers jose
abreu the reigning ale mvp at the plate
the runner and scoring position in two
away bottom one that's right
let's see what happens
it's off the wall and this game
is tied abreu comes through with two
outs
and he's going three he'll be in there
standing
up the middle
right side up the middle right side
keeps it on the ball but that shows you
right there by bucks has got that ball
max kepler is a great corner outfielder
but that's nice
that's not a big league center fielder
this ball should be caught only miggy
and nolan arnado faster
among active players to reach 700 career
rbis he comes in with a 381 batting
average i mean this dude he looks like a
pro wrestler this is what the ball is
looking like to this guy i mean looks
like slow pitch softball right well
maybe it is sloping softly
i mean this is what this ball looks like
to this guy right now i like the
nickname we gave him bam bam look at
this two-strike approach
he almost hit that with both feet off
the ground no they're they're yeah
you're right his back foot was off the
ground it's gonna hit him
mercedes comes through again he is a
machine right now
and the white sox take the lead billy
hamilton working his way back into the
count against j-hat man aboard in
chicago here's billy hamilton if this
gets down it's going to the wall let's
watch billy run
vaughn is being waved around billy
hamilton one of the fastest players in
the game
is into third easily
he didn't even follow me let's let's
follow vaughn because we know billy's
making it
when i saw billy hamilton signed with
the white sox i was so happy for him
because you just know tony larussa is
going to use him properly
you know what else is going to happen
for them
and you can watch this down the stretch
with the new rule now of that 10th
ending you put that run at second base
hello billy you're in the game
that's worth signing him for that's 11
that's 10 you're gonna have 10 or 11
extra in the games probably in the
season that's great that could be 10 or
11 wins for you with him starting at
second base here's danny mendick oh it's
gonna be a run
with billy hamilton running of course it
is he slides in head first it's 4-1
white sox that's the speed speed's so
fun to watch speed let's get back to
speed please
joining us now is him tory hunter
himself what up t
what's going on fellas how you guys
doing second and third wow for the twins
they try to play comeback down by three
josh allison's still swinging a
beautiful piece of hitting there that
was 1993 baseball shooting the ball
right through the hole yeah
you know he's from the old school of
course uh whenever you got a guy like
dallas keiko who's throwing that
two-seamer down and away which i've
faced him several times you have to
shoot that ball the other way andrew
vaughn
still looking for his first big league
homer i believe tonight is the
[Applause]
this would be the night andrew vaughan
picks up his first big league home run
had that feeling in my bad knee guys
a missile
84 mile an hour cutter from j hat that's
the pitch he needs to get down and into
the right he's at that back foot that
one started out outer third kind of spun
back over the middle of the plate
gotta be honest i'm a little frustrated
that billy hamilton is stationary in
this room oh he's gonna run no he's not
i think he will oh harold you're so
smart there he goes no shot at him man
come on now set that bump he's gone he
starts he walks off early talking to
polanco
see you later i'm out of here so what
you do in that situation greg
oh look at tim anderson ground ball
through the infield hamilton scores and
the white sox have a full run lead in
the bottom of the fourth
who comes through again for the white
sox one run will score the throw home
up the line abraham will be into second
safely white sox are nine and one when
jose abreu drives in a run
pretty good numbers right
they're on their way to being ten and
one granddale's got no marks because he
hasn't been real hot yet
the other thing about tony larussa he's
not dropping him in the lineup because
he knows he's going to run into one
eventually he's going to get that he
just did he started last night hit a big
three-run bomb last night
he's gonna get there
talk about you he's coming
that was nice yo mankata bases loaded
this is a gapper from yamankata it's
going to score two
this game is trending
in a direction
where i believe
we may see a position player pitch in
the six and miguel seno who's already
struck out facing kykel not known for
case
broken bat
will it be caught look at jose abreu
he does it all you can put a highlight
reel together and your back blows up you
don't mind it on the base hit but not a
little flare like this
that's a good base running
not to take off
luis arrives over the bases loaded two
away in a 12-5 game in chicago oh my
louise arrives and the twins are trying
to make this a ball game
we're in the sixth inning fellas and
it's now a five-run deficit if they lose
tonight it'll be their second straight
loss they'll fall to 16 and 20. there he
goes a second
mitch garver
third base that's got to be a pass paul
grandahl scores
13-7 liam hendricks is on the mound who
has really evolved over the years hasn't
he he really has greg and he's went from
a guy that was a fifth sixth inning guy
to really finding himself signed that
big contract here he is with the toronto
blue jays and a little bit different
look you see he's look at his velocity
92 to 94 miles an hour and really
falling off towards first base he
cleaned that up a lot look at the jump
and spike and velo from 92 to 97 and
this is what has been the difference up
in the zone with that four seamer 98
last year he touched 100 a couple times
when he's up in the zone with two
strikes it makes that hard breaking ball
and he has a good one but this is what
sets it up and he's in attack mode you
see he's 97 and 99 consistently
he's got his phone ready slider let's
stand police sack you know a thing or
two
the white sox continue to cruise